hey everyone
welcome to simply learns youtube channel
in our last session we discussed what is
correlation and correlation coefficient
you can find a link to that video in our
description
in this session
we will continue the discussion and look
into different types of correlation
so let's discuss the agenda for today's
session
we'll start the tutorial by
understanding what is correlation
then we'll move to discuss types of
correlation and discuss each of them one
by one after that we learn the two major
methods to calculate correlation
coefficient that is pearson's
correlation and spears1 rank correlation
so let's get started
what is correlation
correlation refers to a statistical
relationship between the two entities
it measures the extent to which two
variables are linearly related
for example
the increase in the height of the
children is accompanied often by the
increase in weight
the value of the correlation always lies
between minus one two plus one
there are mainly three categories of
correlation
the first one is positive correlation
and negative correlation
the second one is linear and non-linear
correlation
and the third one is simple multiple and
partial correlation
let's discuss each of them one by one
positive correlation
a positive correlation means that a
linear relationship is positive
and the two variables increases or
decreases in the same direction as you
can see from the graph
for example
the calories you burn is directly
proportional to the amount of time you
run on a treadmill on the other hand a
negative correlation is just the
opposite
the relationship line has a negative
slope and the variable changes in the
opposite direction that is one variable
decreases while the other increases
an example can be a student who has many
absence has a decreasing grades
now let's move on to discuss linear and
nonlinear correlation
when we change the value of a variable
which leads to a constant ratio change
in other variable
then that relation is said to be linear
for example
the factory doubles its output by
doubling the number of workers on the
other hand correlation is said to be
non-linear when the amount of change in
one variable is not in constant ratio to
the change in the other variable
for example
the change in radius of the sphere and
the change in volume of the same sphere
does not happen to be in the same ratio
now let's discuss simple multiple and
partial correlation
when studying the relationship between
the variables when only two variables
are involved the correlation is said to
be simple
in the multiple correlation we measure
the degree of association between one
variable on the one side and all the
variables together on the other side
and for the partial correlation we study
the relationship of one variable with
one of the other variables presuming
that all the variables remains constant
now that we know all the types of
correlation
let's discuss the two major types to
calculate the correlation coefficient
the first one is pss correlation pss
correlation coefficient is the test
statistics that measures the statistical
relationship between the two continuous
variables the ps's correlation
coefficient is often denoted by r and
the formula to calculate the psense
relation coefficient is sigma x i minus
x bar into y i minus y bar divided by
under root sigma x i minus x bar whole
square and y i minus y bar whole square
but r is the coefficient of correlation
x y is the mean of x variable and y bar
is the mean of y variable and x i and yy
denotes the samples of variable x and y
respectively
the psl's coefficient coefficient is the
best
method to measure the association
between two variables
of interest because it gives information
about the magnitude of the association
or correlation
as well as the direction of the
relationship between the two variables
the second best method is ps1 rank
correlation
this psn rank correlation is used to
discover the strength of a link between
the two sets of data
the formula to calculate this psn rank
correlation coefficient is
rho is equal to 1 minus 6 sigma di whole
square divided by n bracket n square
minus 1
where rho is this ps1 rank correlation
coefficient di is the difference between
the two ranks of each observations and n
is the number of observations
so with this we have come to an end to
this tutorial
thank you all for watching this session
we hope you enjoyed it if you have any
questions feel free to put them in the
comment section of this video thank you
again and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here